okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness has a major post credit scene
that teases towards some big things in
the future of the mcu in it we get clear
and present danger as we learn that
steven is a doctor who has caused an
incursion this is a major thing in the
marvel universe and it's all leading
towards secret wars throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
what that is because it's a secret along
with the mystery character and also what
we think would be happening down the
line now i'm aware that the movie has
just come out so if you haven't seen it
then here's your green light to stop
watching the video it's a red light for
anyone who wants to go past this point
and please hit the thumbs up button to
pay pizza poppa without the way thanks
for clicking this now let's get into the
video now there are two endings for the
film the first one being where we watch
strange walking down the street before
he collapses and an eye shoots open in
the middle of his forehead this would be
a big cliffhanger to end things on
however the post-credits scene follows
him once more walking down the street
and everything seems fine it is possible
that this is actually a variant strange
but the world around them looks exactly
like new york so i do believe it's the
main one from the mcu at this point he's
approached by clear played by charlie's
their own and it confirms a fast and the
furious crossover
well wanda did only care about family
unless you read richard's kids but
moving on now she says that strange has
caused an incursion and that they're
gonna fix it throughout the movie we
heard the word incursion at several
points and in it we learned of two
doctor strangers that both caused one
and the repercussions of them the first
was supreme strange founder of the
illuminati who had been using the dark
hole to dreamwalk into other worlds in
the film we discovered that dreams are
actually versions of ourselves living
out their lives in the multiverse
therefore dreamwalking allows you to
astral project into these realities
where you can take control through
wonder we see this allows someone a
puppet a variant of themselves in
another universe but stay too long and
it has disastrous effects if someone
spends too much time in an alternate
reality it causes the one they're from
to bleed together with the one they're
in now and if they stay too long and
leave too big of a mark then this can be
irreversible this is how america is able
to travel from universe to universe and
stay in the 616 at the end because she's
the only version of herself that exists
across the multiverse it's also why
doctor strange and christine can't be
together at the end because they're from
different realities now supreme strange
did this and the illuminati killed him
in order to stop the bleed this saved
their universe but we meet another
strange who wasn't killed and the
incursion he caused destroyed an entire
reality along with most of his
things just got out of hand
no incursions are a big deal and in the
comics we watched several of them happen
and the storyline time runs out several
worlds hurt towards each other on a path
of destruction and the heroes had to
fight their opposites on the world that
was at risk of destroying theirs if they
won they were safe however if they lost
then their entire reality was wiped out
and those characters ceased to exist it
was a major event and led to almost
every earth going head-to-head however
with these constant worlds crashing into
each other it eventually led to the
collapse of the entire multiverse which
went into secret wars this was somewhat
brought up by he who remains in loki in
the final episode he discovered that
there were universes
stacked
on top of the zoo for a while there was
peace
narcissistic self-congratulatory peace
using the best of their universes to
improve the others
some of us
new worlds meant only one thing new
lands to be
conquered each variant fighting to
preserve their
universe and annihilate
the others a secret wars from 2015 is
not to be confused with the one from
1984 in which spider-man got his black
suit though some of the characters do
tie over from that major event what
happened in it was that the world was
turned into a reality known as battle
world with all the continents basically
being their own characters from their
own realities here's a helpful map with
locations like number 7 spider island
which is also a real place on our world
and according to carl pilkington it's
where the spiders have won anyway doom
oversaw this reality and he was viewed
as a god that all worshiped there were
still several wars that happened on this
planet some major deaths and it was hell
on earth however in the end everything
was destroyed and this created a new
timeline or rather earth in which
several of the characters from the
expanded universes were brought across
into the main one miles morales for
example had been a character made purely
for the ultimate comics but this event
allowed him to cross over onto the prime
earth so that he could interact with
characters from it i feel like rather
than doom though that they're gonna
instead have kang at the heart of this
and that he will be the one ruling over
it all this will end with one of his
variants defeating him who will become
he who remains and the cycle will start
all over again as was prophesied by the
character at the end of loki this
explains how he had the script with
everything in it and it will once more
lead to a choice he can either hand
control over to loki and selvi or die
and the multiverse will break open once
more starting the whole thing over again
stranger was told multiple times not to
use the dark hole to dreamwalk but the
guy didn't really care so the 616
strange causing an incursion is pretty
big but this post credit scene is
important because we watch him running
towards the danger instead of away from
it with clear at his side he stands a
chance but who is she what are her hopes
and also her dreams well that's what
we're going to get into for the next
part of the video now clears the
daughter of prince oraney and umar who
just so happens to be the sister of
dormammu together they lived in the dark
dimension and they worshipped the
villain seeing him as a god clear even
ended up becoming the source for a
supreme of that reality and the tear she
opens up leads directly there strange of
course defeated dormammu at the end of
his first solo film and it's like that
those in it would know who he was it is
possible that he even caused an
incursion all the way back then as he
spent a vast amount of time in the
dimension due to the time stone it's a
lot of time you why me wibbly wobbly
stuff that i'm not 100 sure on but i
thought i'd drop that in to explain why
they might be going there now it is also
important to bear in mind that dormammu
is still alive so we will potentially
meet him once more in this reality i
discussed this on our last video but
just to go over it again there are
theories that dormammu is actually a
strange variant he was originally
supposed to be voiced by tony todd but
they changed this up in the movie to
make it so that benedict cumberbatch did
the performance this was said at the
time to be because dormammu took on his
attributes due to him being the only
life form around but they could go that
route if they really want to if they do
this then i doubt they're going to make
her dormammu's niece because strange and
clear actually end up married also
dormammu is pretty much andros whereas
clear looks like a normal person so meh
doubt they'll go that way unlike
christine the pair can date without
causing an incursion and this is because
she can travel realities without dream
walking so they could end up dating down
the line and that would help him get
over christine who's now married to a
number one doctor strange fan now in the
comics the ancient one became aware of
dormammu's plans to take over earth and
she sent strange to the dark dimension
in order to investigate here clear
spotted him and she followed him taking
a shine to the guy she tried to get
strange to avoid fighting him and when
he refused dormammu imprisoned her i
can't see this being sort of what they
do in the film and potentially when
strange ended the dark dimension she may
have seen him eventually she was freed
and they ended up working together now
we know from the conversation at the end
that clear one strange to help fix an
incursion i love the way that this
strange has learned from the mistakes of
the other two and that he's heading
towards it instead of letting himself
die or a universe be destroyed and the
third eye opening up could also show
he's mastered his corruption or it may
hint he's toying with it too much the
illuminati did say that they're strange
refused to stop dreamwalking which
caused a lot of issues the third eye is
also something that's appeared in the
comics and it's shown up when strange
was corrupted now because all the dark
olds were destroyed there is potential
that strange managed to get it under
control and that might be why it doesn't
really seem to be affecting him here
lots of interesting ways it can take
things and i think the next doctor
strange film will set up more of secret
wars there are rumors that a lot of
cameos and moments were originally
planned for this film but that things
were held back i'm guessing that they
didn't want to blow their load first
film and have saved some cameos for down
the line when we get more multiverse
movies this current phase in the mcu
seems all about bringing variants in so
my guess is that we will build the
secret wars with kang at the center of
it the guy is a time traveler from the
future who's constantly tried to rule
the multiverse and he's such a great
villain to build up too now be unclear
we might actually get somewhat of a
multiversal team-up movie like what we
had and what if just in the same way
that the watcher and strange supreme
ended up recruiting heroes from across
different timelines clear my two she
could be a nick fury-esque figure that
unites them all together and it would
mean that we can get different versions
of characters like what we had in the
shows and the phase 4 movies it could
end up getting loki as well who we last
left looking over a statue of kang going
forward i think we're going to see some
universes destroyed preferably the
morbius one now sony are clearly
ignoring the rules of incursions as
michael keaton's vulture is allowed to
run around scot-free but we'll see if
they change that up for the highly
anticipated el muerto movie everything
needs to be brought back together into a
sacred timeline where disney just buys
all the characters back and hopefully
that's where things will be going in the
future though i doubt sony are ever
gonna let go either way it's likely all
gonna start over again and we can watch
the mcu for another 20 years yay
now
shut up for a second and go do something
for me go and read secret wars yeah but
buy beyond the graphic novel get them
expanded stories otherwise you'll have
no idea what's going on i actually read
the main graphic novel two times without
checking out the offshoots and it made
no sense so go do that now the final
post credit scene has peter popper's
hand finally stop attacking him which is
of course a nod to the evil dead and
that's the end of the video now i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of spider-man
no way home on the 15th of may and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
entire breakdown of the movie which will
be linked on screen right now we've gone
over the whole thing you guys love it
we've got some great jokes in there as
well so definitely go check it out right
after this much better than the crab in
this video i promise you that anyway
hopefully i see over there but if not
enjoy your weekend mate take care peace